why should we do exercise daily to gain  muscle or to burn calories  recent research has shown that  exercising daily can help neurogenesis  or birth of new neurons in the  hippocampus hippocampus is our learning  center  it helps us to remember things so it's a  memory center  and daily exercise help in neurogenesis  in hippocampus  now daily exercise also leads to  improvement of synaptic functions the  way neurons connect to each other and  talk to each other also it has been seen  recently that exercise can improve  cognition in alzheimer's patients who  are suffering from memory related  disorders  that's why moral of the story exercise  for a better quality of life that's one  minute see you in next video